So they are four critical resources you need to think about
as we just we talk about their physical resources,
final resources, human resources, and intellectual resources.
Let's take a look at each one.
For physical resources, this might seem at first kind of the obvious is your company facilities
and that is office base, company location
are you in downtown ??? or are you in Ann Arbor Michigan
or you were in Delft in the Netherlands or ???.
Where the best place to locate your companies headquarters
and where are you going to do most of the work.
The second part of physical resources where are you going to get the supply
for your product and services.
So for example you're making silk and whose going to be your silk and weaver supplier
in the value chain or your making still, where are we going to get the iron ore
or are you going to need a thousands of square feet of warehouse space
if you're going to setup a distribution center
and what's really interesting is this kindly obviously a fact where you going to put your company facility.
Maybe you want to have your manufacturing facility next to the city supplier
or you might say, okay we understand their distant and we can manage that remotely
but you need to actually think through not only this relationship
but as you'll see the relationship between resources and the partners part of the business model campus
because some of this supplies and services required deep relationships.
Not just ordering out of a catalogue but true partnerships.
Now the other thing to just remember is many physical goods if they are in a physical channel
are capital intensive which is a fancy word for saying doing a start up like  ??? space ads
is very different than doing a IOS or android.
The amount of resources your going to need for physical goods just are dramatically different
and when your thinking about the finance component,
you have to really think about what happens after year 1, year 2. etc.
How do you scale this business?--And in the 2nd decade of the 21th century
a good number clean text startups like scientist startups are now encountering this phenomenon.
Does this work great as a startup but there is a value of death for a capital and scam.